- Do you know this one?
(keyboard music)
They used to say Portland
didn't have good musicians.
They would say, "Portland?
"Where is that?
"Who do you know in Portland
that's ever done anything?"
And I say, "I know me (laughing),
"and I'm having fun."
(light instrumental music)
- [Chris] I'm Chris Funk.
I'm a musician in a band
called The Decemberists,
and I'm on a journey looking
for the most surprising
and extraordinary people in music.
My next stop takes me
to the soul of Portland.
There, I'll meet Ural Thomas,
the Pacific Northwest godfather
of rhythm and blues.
My town of Portland, Oregon isn't known
for having a thriving R&B scene.
But the Portland I know has a secret.
Hidden in the heart of
the city's music culture
is a master of soul who
has shared the stage
with the likes of Otis
Redding and James Brown.
♪ My sunny days stay bright ♪
This established 78 year old is proving
that great R&B can be found anywhere.
♪ Everything I do with you baby ♪
- [Ural] My name is Ural Thomas.
I'm singing with a band called The Pain.
We have a very unique
style of rhythm and blues.
♪ It's all because of you ♪
♪ Oh, yeah, baby, yeah ♪
♪ Oh, baby ♪
I've been an R&B musician
for over 40 years,
and I've lived in Portland all my life.
(applauding and cheering)
(light guitar music)
- [Chris] Ural's music has taken him
as far as the Apollo Theater in Harlem,
but after experiencing great achievement
the siren song of Portland
lured him back home.
- Hey Chris, how ya doin'?
- [Chris] We met him at his place
known for its infamous Sunday jam sessions
with some of Portland's best musicians.
- Portland, to me, is a very positive place.
So, I come back home where
I know that I'm positive,
and I figure like, uh, maybe I
can do something in Portland
to help musicians.
I really have enjoyed sharing my soul.
There are no word shirts
to explain that feeling;
it's like magic.
- [Chris] Ural has played
music through segregation
and the Civil Rights Movement,
watching Portland transition
into the city it is today.
- The Pacific Northwest
was very segregated.
There was a lot of
places that black singers
and stuff couldn't go.
So then we had opportunity
to show the people
what music was really about.
It wasn't about being divided.
We didn't have no black and white,
because we all did it together.
(cheering and clapping)
I've played with some very
amazing people in my life
like Mick Jagger, Otis
Redding, Carla Thomas,
wonderful people.
It was a blessing for me
to have all the experiences
that I can say that I was a part of.
♪ Don't write to me ♪
- [Chris] Ural's musical
journey has taken him
around the country,
but I'm happy he's made his
way back home to Portland
because every city needs
an unexpected treasure.
- I'm back home now with
the most wonderful group
that I could ever deal with.
The guys are called The Pain,
and we're gonna bring it.
(applauding)
Oh, man.